every state should do what Arizona did
and say look we don't care about you
want you want out of this one I'll tell
you it's really simple the left is
complaining about the right because you
know Kerry lake is filing his lawsuits
and they say you won't get over 2020 I'm
like all right all right everybody slow
down here's an idea no more foreign
built voting machines
it doesn't even like I don't understand
the argument against it it's like what
we got to spend money to get up upgraded
voting machines for election security
everybody should be in favor of that we
make them here in America that's
American jobs good working class jobs we
do open source codes that people have a
right to see the code why would any
Democrat disagree with that it's a
requirement for all of our defense
Contracting so why wouldn't it be for
our voting system have you looked much
into the blockchain for voting uh
security you know blockchain really
offers a lot of look it's it's immutable
it's distributed Ledger it's a more
secure way it's I mean frankly the most
secure Computing system is truly uh
available with the proof of work kind of
architecture but a lot of people don't
understand it for one